have you ever seen a postcard or a
travel book with one of these on it this
is called a torii gates and is a
characteristic symbol of Shinto or
Shintoism now there are a lot of videos
on YouTube and Internet's that talks
about Shinto and describes it as japan's
native religion or sometimes also as a
religion that's based somehow on nature
worship but most modern scholarship
suggests that these ideas are wrong or
at least partly misguided
but what is Shinto and how can it be
properly understood the word Shinto
wasn't perhaps something that a lot of
people are familiar with but the outer
expressions of this tradition probably
hasn't escaped anyone who has ever come
into contact with sort of media
surrounding Japan in some way the torii
gates the shrines the priests the
rituals it's all a very common sight in
any kind of media surrounding the
country of Japan Shinto literally means
way of the gods shin meaning God or
deity and Thor meaning way being
basically the same word as the Chinese
Dao from Taoism it is today used to
designate certain religious beliefs and
practices in Japan that are distinct
from Buddhism these so called other
major religion in the region but this
distinction would have been a foreign
concept to people in earlier periods of
history and this is where the first and
main problem arises which makes it
difficult to talk about the basic
principles of Shinto the idea of Shinto
as a separate and distinct religion is
in fact a rather new idea one that
stretches back primarily to the 19th
century and the appearance of the Meiji
period and its reforms prior to this the
connection between Shinto and Buddhism
was a lot closer than the one is often
imagined today being basically
indistinguishable from each other
in any case the basic tenants of Shinto
as we know it are related primarily to
shrines rituals and certain myths a
central idea is Shinto is something
known as kami
which is often translated as gods or
spirits none of which really captures
its actual meaning but it does have
similarities with ideas of deities we
find an
other polytheistic or pagan traditions
with certain kami being associated with
natural phenomena or places these were
often viewed in very human ways and seen
as kind of dangerous spirits who could
for example destroy your crops if you
weren't careful and so what happened was
that priests started to perform rituals
and build shrines in certain locations
associated with kami where he would
perform rituals to appease the calming
in a kind of exchange where the priests
would give the comi what he wanted and
the coming would sort of leave the
people alone this all appears to have
occurred in ancient times but without
any kind of conception that this
practice or these rituals were part of
any sort of larger system of thought or
or religious tradition at all many of
the myths surrounding these commits come
from two main scriptures or sources the
kojiki and the nihon shoki both composed
in the eighth century by the new ruling
yamato dynasty and associated with
something known as the dingey cult in
these scriptures many of the kami that
would remain significance throughout
history were introduced or at least
placed within an official mythology the
most important and famous of these is
probably the deity Amaterasu viewed as
the Sun Goddess Amaterasu is especially
important because she is directly
connected to the Imperial rule the
emperor considered to be her direct
descendant and thus the legitimate ruler
of Japan she appears again again
throughout history with various myths
surrounding her the most famous of which
is a story in which after a rivalry
between her and her brother Shi Cerf
yuri ously hides in a cave and because
of course she is the Sun goddess that
sort of plunged the world into darkness
in other gods the other kami are very
concerned about this and so they try to
come up with some idea of how they can
bring her out of the cave again and so
they come up with this plan where one of
the gods starts dancing outside the cave
and the other kami started laughing and
basically just making
in general a party atmosphere and this
interests Amaterasu who peeks outside
the cave and she is met with her own
reflection because the other gods have
placed a mirror in front of the opening
to the cave and so with this sort of
shock of seeing herself she exits the
cave completely after which the other
coming closest the entrance and forces
her to stay outside again which brings
the Sun brings light back into the world
once again in fact many of the myths
such as this one and rituals of the
Ginga cult were specifically constructed
to legitimize the emperor larger shrines
were then developed like the ISA shrine
for example which was dedicated to
Amaterasu where priests were sort of
permanent employees that would perform
many different rituals many of which
were the specific purpose of reinforcing
the Emperor's connection to the Sun
goddess and thus his authority was
reinstated many of these shrines also
survived today being regularly visited
by the Japanese for special occasions
the shrines function like houses for the
comi much like that of a human being and
the priests and as we will see later
monks make sure that the kami is
satisfied and happy through different
rituals it is believed that kamek can
help you with certain problems or
obstacles so many visitors shrine today
to pray for for example good results or
an exam or in preparation for a job
interview and of course a lot of people
pray for less mundane things as well the
shrines are also commonly visited for
special occasions like New Year
celebrations and other festivals when
visiting a shrine one first enters
through the large torii gate on either
the left side or the right side never in
the center this is because the center is
reserved for the comi themselves and
avoided out of courtesy later you must
also clean yourself before approaching
the shrine proper this is done at a
specific cleaning station with certain
scoops that you use to ritually cleanse
yourself in a very specific order when
approaching the shrine and the home of
the kami it is common to leave a gift
through money you then ring a bell to
summon the God before bowing twice and
then clapping twice
and then after your prayer is concluded
you bow again and then leave it's
difficult to know how long these
specific practices have been in force
but it is the general practice of shrine
visits today aside from the daily
rituals and offerings at these shrines
there are also larger rituals in which
the entire community is involved and
these often includes parades or
specifically very commonly recreations
of the mythical stories in the kojiki
and nihon shoki in these rituals the
kami will be transferred from their
houses in these shrines the regular
houses and transferred into a kind of
portable house called a mikoshi
and this Nicosia will then be carried
around to perform certain scenes or
parts of this mythological play the
mikoshi are very interesting because it
is thought that the kami and its powers
are contained within this portable house
at least for the duration that they are
thought to be in there there's a
fascinating example from I think
somewhere in the Middle Ages when
Buddhist monks sort of rebelled against
the government in Kyoto and thus came
down from the HEA a mountain carrying
mikoshi and placed them outside of the
city as a means of warfare and of course
everyone in the city was terrified other
rituals and ceremonies include what we
could call theater dramatic reenactments
of the myths which took different forms
sometimes including singing and dancing
which is called Kagura there's a wealth
of different practices and traditions
related to Japanese religion that I
can't sort of contain in this video but
I highly recommend studying it further
it is very interesting stuff as I
mentioned earlier the sort of common
idea what Shinto is and where it comes
from is somewhat of a contested issue in
a fairly recent book called a new
history of Shinto authors John Breen and
mark two and discussed these issues at
length and shows how Shinto cannot be
viewed as an independent entity for most
of history a very common way to view the
history of Shintoist is conceived of
this sort of ancient pure period when
Shinto was in its well its purest form
before the interference of Buddhism and
Confucianism and the
wages that sort of contaminated it and
then finally being separated again at
the late 19th century and sort of
regaining that original purity but this
view is almost completely rejected today
the historian of Japanese history Kuroda
Toshiro argues that before modern times
Shinto did not exist as an independent
religion and that it should rather be
viewed as a component or extension of
Japanese Buddhism indeed historically
aside from the Imperial courts and their
strategy of legitimizing their rule
through establishing a cult surrounding
the kami
the second important factor here is
Buddhism which was but could be called
the state religion from much of Japan's
history
now remember Buddhism and Shinto should
not be viewed as two distinct tradition
that merged but Buddhism did have a
large influence on what we call Shinto
today as Buddhism viewed the Buddha as
being above the gods and the gods also
being in need of seeking Nirvana and
liberation its practitioners simply
implemented the Kama cults as part and
parcel of Japanese Buddhism the
developed temple shrine complexes which
contain both Buddhist temples and
monasteries as well as shrines dedicated
to the kami the Buddhist monks would
read the sutras sayings of the Buddha to
the kami in order to help them on the
way to Nirvana for example thus what we
call Shinto was simply a unique aspect
of Japanese Buddhism in spite of the
indistinguishability of Buddhism and
Shinto historically it hasn't always
been a walk in the park obviously on
some occasions there have been conflicts
between the Buddhist monks and the
priests of the Commish Rhines in the
late 15th to early 16th century there
was a significant change in attitude in
some areas whereas before the kami had
been seen as inferior beings in need of
Buddhist guidance now some were viewing
the kami as the ultimate source of all
existence this increasing importance of
the kami developed further under Yoshida
kana Tomo who founded something known as
one and only Shinto in which practice is
referred to as Shinto was in some way
intellectually separated from Buddhist
practices it is in fact around this time
that the word Shinto was used for the
first time as well
this development of separating shinto
conceptually from buddhism sort of
developed and evolved over time until
the late 19th century with the meiji
Revolution when Shinto was officially
separated from Buddhism as in other
periods Shinto then became an imperial
ideology one meant to legitimize its
rule the idea of the sort of pure
original Shinto before Buddhist
influence developed thus here as a kind
of nationalistic myth of a pure Japanese
culture pure Japanese mythology so the
Shinto we see today is the result of a
long history of development and change
certain aspects does date back to
ancient times but much of it is also
very modern one should remember that
this is still a living tradition and the
Shinto shrines and rituals do still play
a large role in the everyday lives of a
lot of people in Japan this video has to
a large degree been about whether Shinto
has historically been an independent
religion but this of course depends on
how we define the word religion itself
viewed from a very rested and
Christocentric perspective what religion
is Shinto can't live up to those
requirements for most of its history but
perhaps this more than anything shows us
how fluid and undefined the term
religion itself really is the lines
between Buddhism and Shinto has always
been blurry and non-existent and the
situation today also kind of mirrors
that many people in Japan could consider
themselves to be Buddhist but they still
visit the Shinto shrines even more
people in Japan perhaps identifies
atheists and even they have a strong
connection to these shrines so how do we
define this is I like are they a theist
are they Shinto it really shows us that
a lot of our terms that we understand
the world with or that we use for these
different religious traditions are very
limited and can often create more
confusion than anything else the world
of religious beliefs and practices in
the world is a lot more complicated than
we like to believe and this is a good
example of this that sort of really
opens your mind to the incredibly
complex world of religion and the
different ways in which it can manifest
itself but how will you define Shinto is
it
religion or if not then how would you
define a religion leave your comments
and we'll continue this discussion there
I'll see you next time
[Music]